(guitar music)
- Hi, I'm Raymond Simpson,
I'm a museum assistant here
at the Peabody Museum in entomology
and today, I'm going to
show you a bunch of insects
from Central and South America,
that are quite interesting
from a biodiversity standpoint
and also from an evolutionary standpoint.
So before we get started,
I'm going to kind of
give you a nice overview
of the various arthropod species,
that we see that our non non
butterfly and moth actually.
So this is a good diversity,
a good illustration of the diversity
of basically non-lepidopteran arthropods
from the tropics.
So lepidoptera would be
butterflies and moths,
so there's many other groups of insects
that are basically reach peak
diversity in the tropics.
So you have everything from non-insects
like scorpions, scorpions,
whip, scorpions, tarantulas,
and then centipedes, and millipedes,
and then you also have insects
that vary from this large Katydid
which is a type of
related to grasshoppers,
you have these large
plant hoppers, cicadas,
roaches, and beetles.
So today, I'm going to just
give you a little brief overview
of a lot of this amazing
interest insect diversity
that is found in Latin America.
So there's multiple
themes that come into play
when you're talking about
insects in the Neotropics.
With these type of insects,
and there are a couple
one is basically size,
which you kind of got
an idea based on these.
A lot of insects range from
very small, to very large,
as illustrated by a lot of
these insects in the box here.
This is kind of the large
size variation in insects
but you could see that
there's ranges from basically the largest
like this is one of the largest
grasshoppers in the world,
but there's also grasshoppers
that are much smaller
under an inch in length.
So there's grasshoppers that range from
basically a few centimeters to
nearly like basically
like 10 centimeters across
and there's a lot of variation
in both size and shape.
So here we have a
basically these are
two types of Orthoptera
which are crickets,
katydids and grasshoppers.
This is a winged grasshopper
but this is a wingless cricket.
This is like a wheat ground cricket
and this up here
is a wingless Katydid
and entomologist studying
this internal of heart
by subtle differences in morphology.
So there's a lot of variation
from huge to very small
but the most striking thing you can note
in arthropods in the tropics,
is what we call sexual dimorphism
and sexual dimorphism is basically
the sexes of insects, the male and females
have different morphologies.
So dimorphism means there's
two different morphs
based on the insect being male or female.
So, and this video is
called the Hercules beetle,
very common through Central America.
The male, which is on the bottom here,
has these really cool horns
and I will get him out very carefully,
so the male Hercules
beetle has these weapons
that basically what they are
for not only impressing a female
but also fighting with other males.
So they have this like
multiple horned protuberances
that help it fight other males,
so the males will actually
line up with each other
and fight each other
and whoever whatever male knocks
the other male off their perch wins
and then the females
which don't have horns,
will choose them
because they're obviously
the fittest of the males.
So the females are generally
have most scarab beetles
are a lot less ornamented than the males.
Here's another example
of a Hercules beetle.
You could see the horns being
quite long and ornate and a lot of these.
Some of these
dynasties or Hercules
beetles get quite big,
So you can see compared to my hand
this is a very large stag beetle
and you could tell by the horns,
the horn morphology is
different in each species.
So if you get them if you get
an individual of each of these beetles,
you can tell what species
is based on the horn shape.
Another type of beetle at
this interesting dimorphism
and basically like it adaptation
is this Cerambycidae or Longhorn beetle
you might be like why
the heck does it have
such long legs like that?
You could tell it's a longhorn
because it has long antenna
but what are these long legs for
but the males in these are actually
using these in a basically
territorial fashion
to basically display and
to challenge other males.
So if you see any sort
of, there's a pretty
wide variety of these
adaptations that insects have
and if you see these extreme adaptations
in any insect either of color,
shape, or ornamentation,
that usually indicates
some sort of sexual selection is going on,
where the females are
actually choosing males
based on these interesting
and extreme ornamentation
that they have.
So going back to when
I mentioned about size,
size is very important
to insect diversity,
because different sizes allow
for different niche space
niche being the place
the basically the role
that the organism has in its environment.
So if you have different sizes
of these or praying mantises, for example,
if you have different
sized praying mantises,
they could occupy different niches
so you could have smaller ones interacting
in the same environment with larger ones,
where if you have a single praying mantis
like you do in the in like the
northeastern United States,
you have one species and that's it
not a lot of insect diversity
is possible if you have one size.
So if you utilize
multiple sizes of insects,
you could fit a lot more diversity
into a particular area for us.
So these are actually types of mantis.
Like this here is called a hooded Mantis
and these actually sit on
the tops of like banana
like basically large, broad, shiny leaves,
and they perfectly blend
in to their background
and this is a more typical
Mantis similar to the mantis
you get in the United States.
With the typical raptorial four legs
that you can see here
for grasping the press
and then you have smaller more
bark mimic mantises
that actually mimic bark
to actually sit on bark,
and you can't see them
when they're on the bark
because they're so perfectly camouflaged
and then you have these small,
these small species,
which actually mimic other
types of insects mimicry,
meaning they look like them.
So these actually mimic wasps.
So these mantis actually look like wasps.
So they not only are able to
sneak up on potential prey
by looking like a completely
different type of insect
but they're also able to have the mimic
the protection from potential predators
by looking like a wasp.
So you kind of have this double usage
of this mimicry that they use.
Another good example of a large insect
that you probably don't
ever want to encounter
gets stung by,
this is called a tarantula Hawk.
So tarantula Hawk is feeds on
tarantulas, as you'd expect.
So you can see this is
a typical tarantula that
you'd find in the tropics
but these wasps are adapted to kill them
or paralyze them and
feed them to their larva.
So one of these wasps
will actually go over
flip this over on its back
sting its belly where it's less protected,
and then drag it across the ground
and when the wasp brings it to its burrow
it'll put this body of this
paralyzed spider into a burrow
and lay eggs on it
and the larva will actually
eat the spider alive,
just kind of brutal
but because they are adapted
to hunt such large prey,
these Pepsis wasps have
become so like gigantic,
that their stings are very
like you don't want to get stung,
coz they are very, very painful
but they don't tend to be very aggressive
so as long as you leave them alone
they're only interested in spiders,
they're only interested in
hurting spiders, not humans.
So we kind of touched on a little bit
when we're talking about
size and size diversity
but another very important
thing about tropical insects
is camouflage and with a lot
of these none insect to earth
or non butterfly arthropods,
they're more worried about getting eaten
because they can't fly,
So a lot of these will tend
to look like things that aren't edible.
So the walking stick
is probably something a
lot of people have heard of
but the walking stick is
the best example of mimicry
of a non basically a non-living thing.
So these, imagine this on a tray
would be almost perfectly
camouflaged from predators.
So in the case of some walking sticks,
you have this very large one here
on the bottom it's hard to say,
this is a very large species
but you could tell compared to
the one I showed you before,
this is a lot thicker and more textured.
So it's adapted to live
in a different area
than the more gracile
style skinny walking stick
that I showed you before.
So this one is going to be camouflage
on like a prickly bush,
like a picker brush or something
a brush that has some roughness to it.
This is another type right
up here, a little bit bigger.
So while I have this on, we have some
a lot of people are
familiar with plant hoppers
in their gardens In the tropics,
you get giant plant hoppers.
So these this one here
is called a peanut bug,
coz its nose is elongated into this
really cool inflated
projection on the front
and as you'd expect, this is for display
this is for attracting
a mate, so the males
with the most inflated noses
are selected to reproduce.
So a lot of these plant hoppers
are important predators of plants
by sucking the juices out of the stems
but they also reach fairly
impressive proportions
in the tropics.
Cicada which a lot of
people are familiar with
in its head to the
cicada is very well known
for being more like this
size in the United States
but this is what they
get to be in the tropics
and just imagine how loud that is
when that thing's buzzing.
So finally, I'd like
to finish on basically
diversity of color
and beetles are the most numerous,
basically the most numerous
arthropod group on the planet,
probably millions, definitely
hundreds of thousands
of described species were probably
in the range of millions of species
when it's all said and done
and this is just an example of some of the
amazing diversity within a
very small group of beetles
called the jewel scarab beetles
and these jewel scarabs
are ranged from just kind of
normal Browns all the way
to this brilliant green.
Some of them are literally Chrome,
they look like they've
been dipped in Chrome
and it's the jury's still out on what
the adaptive advantage of this Chrome is
but green is apparent because
just like the hooded Mantis,
they could blend into plants very well
these green ones in the brown ones
are very good to blend in with ground cam
basically ground debris and leaves.
So out of these jewels, scarabs
are basically found
throughout Latin America
and they commonly come to light so a lot
of people like to collect
them and observe them
because they are quite easily to see.
So in entomology, there's
a lot of things to study
and a lot of ways to study
there's a lot of life
history, we don't know,
a lot of bio diversity
is completely unstudied,
and anybody from somebody like me
to the any or any citizen
even untrained person
that doesn't know much about insects
can contribute to entomology
by simply getting out
and studying and learning and observing
and YouTube could make positive
contributions to entomology.
Plus, they're just really
beautiful and fun to look at.
So thank you very much.
(guitar music)